INSIGHT.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> YEAH.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: SO THE OPEN BORDERS
CRISIS IS NOT JUST AFFECTING
TEXAS AND ARIZONA AND
CALIFORNIA.
TWO WEEKS AGO HUNDREDS OF
MIGRANTS LANDED IN THE FLORIDA
KEYES.
SO MANY ARRIVED, THEY SHUT DOWN
A NATIONAL PARK.
THERE'S NO SIGNS THAT THIS
INVASION IS GOING TO STOP, SO
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA, RON
DESANTIS, HAS JUST ACTIVATED THE
FLORIDA NATIONAL GUARD.
HE IS ALL CONSIDERING ANOTHER
MAJOR STEP TO SECURE THIS
COUNTRY'S BORDERS, OR AT LEAST
HIS STATE'S BORDERS.
HE'S WEIGHING BAN TO BAN CHINA
FROM PURCHASING REAL ESTATE IN
FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR DESANTIS JOINS US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
YOU'RE ACTIVATING THE NATIONAL
GUARD.
WHAT WILL THEY DO?
>> THEY'VE BEEN HEAVY IN THIS
EVER SINCE WE ACTIVATED, TUCKER,
OVER THE LAST WEEK TO TEN DAYS.
BASICALLY BIDEN IS LEAVING THE
COAST GUARD OUT TO DRY.
HE'S NOT SENDING ANY MORE
VESSELS, SUPPORT.
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO
INTERCEPT ALL THE BOATS THAT ARE
TRYING TO COME, PRIMARILY FROM
CUBA, BUT ALSO HAITI.
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH OUR
ASSETS, WE'RE OUT THERE IN THE
FLORIDA STRAITS.
WE'RE USING RECONNAISSANCE.
WE ARE ALERTING THE COAST GUARD
WHEN BOATS ARE THERE.
WE'RE STOPPING BOATS.
AND THEN THE COAST GUARD ARE
PICKING THESE FOLKS UP.
HERE'S THE THING, TUCKER.
WE THINK THAT SOME OF THIS IS
BEING ORCHESTRATED BY THE CUBAN
GOVERNMENT.
WE THINK THERE'S A LOT OF HUMAN
SMUGGLING GOING ON.
NOT ONLY IS THIS NOT GOOD FOR
THE FLORIDA KEYS, TO HAVE PEOPLE
DUMPED ON THEIR PROPERTY, SOME
OF THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
THESE BOATS ARE BEING
MISTREATED.
I THINK WE'VE SEEN A DECLINE IN
THE NUMBER OF VESSELS THAT ARE
IN THE WATER.
WE HAVE NOT HAD AS MANY
LANDINGS.
ACTUALLY, VERY FEW LATELY.
SO IT IS WORKING AS A DETERRENT.
BUT IT'S OUR SENSE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO CHANGE THEIR TACTICS SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE WATCHING AND
RESPONDING IN KIND.
>> Tucker: THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO DO THIS IS, ITSELF, A
DETERRENT TO SMUGGLERS.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IN
FLORIDA, SO MANY PEOPLE MOVED
THERE.
REAL ESTATE PRICES HAVE GOTTEN
REALLY HIGH.
FOREIGN COUNTRIES BUYING UP MORE
REAL ESTATE DOESN'T HELP MORE
AMERICANS.
THIS IS HAPPENING IN OTHER
STATES AS WELL.
WHAT IS YOUR IDEA FOR DEALING
WITH THIS?
>> WE WANT NO CCP LAND
PURCHASES.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO
IT DIRECTLY.
THEY WILL HAVE SHELL COMPANIES.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE TO SCRUTINIZE
THIS.
WHY WOULD WE WANT THEM BUYING
FARM LAND?
THEY HAD VERY LITTLE FARM LAND
IN THE UNITED STATES EVEN TEN
YEARS AGO.
NOW THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANT
HOLDING.
NOT AS MUCH IN FLORIDA, BUT YOU
DO HAVE IT IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
WHY WOULD WE WANT THE CCP TO OWN
LAND NEAR A MILITARY BASE, OR
NEAR CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A FLAT BAN.
WE'RE GOING TO WORK WITH THE
FLORIDA LEGISLATURE TO GET THAT
DONE.
AMERICAN POLICY MAKERS FOR A
GENERATION HAVE BEEN EMPOWERING
THE CCP.
SAID IT WOULD END UP WORKING
OUT, CHINA WOULD BECOME A
DEMOCRACY.
IN FACT, THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
THREAT TO OUR COUNTRY.
WHY WOULD WE WANT THEM TO HAVE
EVEN MORE INFLUENCE OVER
AMERICAN SOCIETY THAN THEY
ALREADY DO?
>> Tucker: SO VERY SHORT
QUESTION, GOVERNOR.
THESE TWO THINGS.
USING THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
PROTECT THE BORDERS, THESE ARE
THINGS A LOT OF OTHER STATES CAN
BE DOING BUT AREN'T.
IS THIS HARD TO DO?
IS THIS SUPER HARD?
>> THE NATIONAL GUARD WE
CONTROL.
WE'RE PUTTING RESOURCES.
WE HAVE A BIG BUDGET SURPLUS,
TUCKER, SO WE CAN DO THAT.
PEOPLE ARE VERY HAPPY.
WE'RE TAKING CARE OF THE VESSELS
THAT ARE LANDING.
OTHERWISE THE HOMEOWNERS WOULD
HAVE TO PAY $2,500 A POP.
WE'RE STEPPING IN WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S FAILING.
I THINK MORE STATES CAN DO IT,
TUCKER, BUT HONESTLY, WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO BE DOING THIS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
TAKING CARE OF THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE, AND THEY SHOULD BE TAKING
CARE OF THE CCP ISSUE.
WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION, WE
KNOW NEITHER OF THESE TWO THINGS
ARE